SEAN MCQUILLAN: With
picture-in-picture, you
can overlay other apps
where your user is
doing critical tasks, such as
watching a video or navigating.
It's available whenever your
app is running on Oreo or above.
Let's dive in on how
to add it to your app.
A picture-in-picture
overlay is a mode
that you enter from
a visible activity.
The user will see the
contents of the activity
during the entire
transition animation,
so you'll want to
optimize this experience.
Of course, it does count
as a configuration change.
To avoid visual hiccups, make
sure you handle configuration
changes in your activity.
How do you design for PIP?
Well, designing for
Picture-In-Picture, or PIP,
is simple.
It's a small window,
so you simply
hide all of the views that
aren't relevant to the overlay.
For example, if you're
playing a video,
you should only show
the video content
and hide all of the other views
to create a simple overlay.
Another important thing to
note when designing for PIP--
overlays have a fixed aspect
ratio you configure in code.
This lets you specify
the perfect aspect ratio
for your content.
Now, to support user interaction
with your PIP overlay,
you may supply a small number of
controls called remote actions.
You can use remote actions
for simple interaction,
such as playing or
pausing a video.
When in PIP mode, your activity
won't get any touch events.
Instead, you configure remote
actions with PendingIntents.
When a user presses
a remote action,
the PendingIntent will
be fired, and you'll
be notified via a
BroadcastReceiver
or other means.
When your user expands
the overlay back
to a regular activity, you'll
get notified via a callback.
You'll need to reshow
all of your hidden views
when your activity
exits PIP mode.
And there's one
more detail to note.
When an activity
enters PIP mode,
it starts a new task
without a back stack.
When it exits PIP
mode, it does not
bring back the original task.
So by default, Back
will leave your app.
Your user's navigation
history is lost.
To recover your back stack,
check out our blog post
on recovering navigation state.
Picture-in-picture
is a great way
to continue your users' critical
tasks as they use their phone.
I've just covered
the essentials here.
To learn more, check
out the blog post
and documentation on
picture-in-picture
linked in the description.
Thanks for watching.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]